So who's my guest this week?
It's the US Attorney, Gloria Allred.
She calls herself an
avenger for women's rights,
and one glance at her CV gives
that claim serious weight.
Over the last 40 years,
if there's been a high
profile sexual assault case
in America, it's likely
Allred's been the lawyer
for some of the victims.
A lifelong campaigner for equality,
she represented Roe after
the Roe V. Wade case.
She's not without her critics,
who say she's as interested in
publicity as she is justice,
but undeterred at 81 years old,
she has no intention of retiring.
So as America grapples
with abortion rights again,
what does she make of
that Supreme Court ruling?
Here's a taste of what's coming up.
In 2020, you hired a
yellow American school bus
to drive around London,
near Buckingham Palace.
Prince Andrew's face
was on it with a sign,
"If you see this man, please
ask him to call the FBI
to answer their questions."
Is that matter now closed
or are there other avenues?
He to this day has never
agreed to sit with the FBI.
He should be ashamed of himself
that he refuses to do it.
He's avoided.
He's evaded.
He's escaped doing it.
Gloria Allred, thank you
so much for talking to me
for taking some time out
of your busy schedule.
It's wonderful to be able
to talk to you about such
a range of issues today.
And of course, America and
women's rights are global news.
And I wanted to start by asking you,
are you proud to be an
American at the moment?
Well, I'm always very grateful
that my mother came from
the UK to the United States,
and that I was able to grow up here.
And I do have a lot of confidence
in our system of justice and of rights,
but I'm very, very disappointed.
I'm very outraged about
what has happened recently
with the United States
Supreme Court decision
in Roe V. Wade,
but it was inevitable
given some serious flaws
in our system.
Yes, that's what's been talked about
in terms of the way the
justices are appointed,
the political leanings.
I suppose I wanted to ask
you also with that decision
as an attorney, do you have
any sympathy with the view
that abortion shouldn't have
been a constitutional right?
And that there may be merit
in having state-by-state laws?
There's absolutely no merit whatsoever
in throwing the decision
that a woman should
or should not be able to have
an abortion to the states.
It should, and has been
a constitutional right
for a woman to choose whether
or not to bear a pregnancy.
And that has been the law ever since 1973,
when Roe V. Wade was decided
by the United States Supreme Court.
And that a woman did
have a right to choose
whether or not to continue
with her pregnancy,
at least at certain
stages of her pregnancy.
It's very dangerous.
It is barbaric.
It is just an outrage and cruel
to throw this decision to the states.
I'll give you an example, Emma.
Okay, yes, please.
Prior to 1973 and
prior to Roe V. Wade decision,
many states were criminalizing abortion.
So, young women like me
who were in their '20s
and had no resources
would have to try to
gather some money to pay
someone to provide a back alley abortion.
So I was raped at gunpoint in Mexico
when I went there for a vacation,
when I came back to California,
this was in the late '60s,
I found that I was pregnant
and that it was a crime for anyone
to assist with an abortion in California.
So I had to get some money together
for a back alley abortionist
who did provide the abortion,
but left me in a bathtub hemorrhaging
in a pool of my own blood.
And he said that he could not
help me after the abortion.
911 was called to take me to the hospital.
And there I was taken to a unit
where they would try
to save a woman's life
if she was hemorrhaging from an abortion.
The police came and interviewed me,
which was very frightening to me
because I didn't know if
the name I would give them
would be the name of the
real person who provided it,
or if I should give a name at all
for fear that he would do something to me
if I gave the name, which I didn't.
I was packed in ice, I
had 106 degree fever.
I almost died from an illegal abortion,
and the nurse who was
anti-choice said to me,
"I hope this teaches you a lesson."
And I say that it did teach me a lesson.
And the lesson is that abortion
should be safe and legal
and available and affordable,
and no woman or girl should
have to risk her life
with an illegal abortion.
I was just going to say,
and thank you for sharing that.
I know you've spoken
about your experiences
because they are very
relevant and highly traumatic
and you don't want to
go back to that place.
But one of the arguments mounted
by those who are in favor
of this decision is,
well, women can travel,
women can go to other states,
but of course, if they
don't have the means
like you are saying,
and they don't have the
wherewithal or can't get in touch
with those who can help them,
then they won't be able to.
And I just wanted to ask you,
are you expecting as an attorney
to have some clients now who come to you
who may end up, this hasn't
happened yet being prosecuted
for either ordering abortion pills online
or trying to cross state boundaries?
How concerned are you about that?
Well, you raise another very
important issue, actually,
a number of important issues.
So for example, you just
mentioned medication abortions.
Medication abortions are about half
of all of the abortions
in the United States.
The anti-choice movement,
the movement that believes
that a fertilized egg
should have more rights
than an adult woman is trying to interfere
with medication abortions.
For example, to suggest to legislators
that the pill can only be sent
if a doctor is seen in person,
which many women are not able to do,
it also invades their privacy
because we are also concerned
by the anti-choice forces,
trying to obtain medical records,
to find out when a woman is menstruating.
You also mentioned the right
to travel to other states,
Emma, that's a significant issue.
There are many poor women
who can't afford childcare.
These are just some of the
problems that are now existing
for a woman to travel to another state.
Of course, wealthy women
will always be able to travel
to another state
or another country like
Canada to get an abortion.
Indeed, and on those issues and
the complications that are going to arise,
do you think Joe Biden has
done enough to demonstrate
to the women of America
who are of your view
and are worried about this,
that this is not okay,
that this is not the America
that he wants to preside over?
Has he done enough?
I think that the President knows
that there are so many challenges
now facing women and girls
because of this dangerous decision,
he has very limited
ability to do anything.
The main challenge
is that we're going to have
to get everyone to come out
to vote in the upcoming election.
We must remember in November
is our Clarion call.
Our Clarion cry for justice.
What that means is,
that pro-choice voters
are going to have to vote
in both federal and state elections
for pro-choice elected officials.
And we must throw out of office
the anti-choice compulsory pregnancy crowd
that is passing these
restrictive and dangerous laws
in the states and also is
causing essentially paralysis
in the Congress and the
United States Senate.
We must elect more pro-choice
United States senators
and representatives in the house
of representatives as well.
I was minded to bring up to
you a very striking remark
she's known for them - from Fran Lebowitz,
the writer and commentator.
She's recently compared
the Republican Party
to the Taliban regarding
control over women's bodies.
What do you make of that comparison?
Well, I can understand why she said it.
Because this is controlling
women's choices and their lives.
It's often been said, Emma,
that if we can't control,
if we cannot control our
lives from the skin in,
we cannot control our
lives from the skin out.
And this is about even more
than reproductive choice
because not being able
to choose what we do
with our own bodies
means that there is
going to be interference
with our educational opportunities,
our business opportunities,
our physical opportunities,
our emotional opportunities,
and it is going to have a draconian impact
on each and every woman's life.
We cannot go back.
We will not go back
and we must have a passion to fight back,
to win back our rights.
I wanted to just come to Norma McCorvey,
who was Roe in this case,
you later represented her.
You worked with her, but she later,
despite having become once
her name was known synonymous
with this case that granted
women until recently,
constitutional rights to abortion,
she changed sides publicly.
She went against choice.
She went against abortion,
and then it was revealed
that she'd been paid by
that side of the debate
to assume that position
just before she died,
that was revealed.
Did you know she had been paid?
And what did you make
of that whole episode,
having known the woman
who was known as Roe?
Look, every woman gets to make the choice
that she wants to make.
I don't control any woman's choice.
I don't try to do that.
That's what the anti-choice people do.
So yes, was it disappointing?
Of course, but did I try to coerce her?
That's not my role.
It's not anybody's role,
but she admitted the truth in the end.
I'm glad that she did it.
Let me bring you to
another area of your work
which is representing victims
of sexual abuse and sexual assault.
Because recently Ghislaine Maxwell
was sentenced to 20 years
for recruiting and trafficking
14 girls for sexual abuse,
of course, in connection
to Jeffrey Epstein.
It's very striking although
a woman has gone to prison,
but we still don't know the
names of the other men involved.
Yeah, I have no idea what
the prosecutors have in mind.
Federal prosecutors hold their cards
very, very close to their vest.
And they're known for that.
So I have no idea what
they're planning next
or if they're planning anything else
in reference to prosecuting
any other individuals
who might have been
involved with Ms. Maxwell
and with Jeffrey Epstein.
And just following on from that again
about whether something is closed
or there could be further actions
because of your experience
I wanted to ask you,
but also because of something you did,
and coming to Prince Andrew,
in 2020 you hired a
yellow American school bus
to drive around London,
near Buckingham Palace.
I know you remember it.
Some others will remember it.
Prince Andrew's face was
on it, saying with a sign.
"If you see this man,
please ask him to call the FBI
to answer their questions."
And as you say, because
you were representing
some of Jeffrey Epstein's victims.
Earlier this year, Prince
Andrew did come to a settlement
with Virginia Giuffre,
Prince Andrew's always
denied any wrongdoing.
Is that matter now closed
or are there other avenues?
I did that because I wanted
Prince Andrew to cooperate
and give an interview to the FBI
about what he knew about Jeffrey Epstein.
Anything else they
wanted to ask about him?
Since Prince Andrew stayed
in many residences
owned by Jeffrey Epstein
and where young girls were
present, he never did that.
In other words, he gave
an interview to the BBC.
That of course was not under oath.
And it was a complete catastrophe
from a PR point of view.
I wanted him to sit with the FBI
and testify under oath or
even if not under oath,
his duty legally would
be to tell the truth
which he had no duty to do to the BBC,
although it would've been nice.
Don't know if he did it or not.
He never did it.
The civil settlement that you mentioned
had nothing to do with the criminal case
being prosecuted against Ms. Maxwell,
and nothing to do with anything
but the criminal justice system,
he to this day has never agreed
to sit with the FBI.
He should be ashamed of himself,
that he refuses to do it, he's avoided.
he's evaded, he's escaped doing it.
Now the criminal case against
Ms. Maxwell will go on appeal,
but I say it's never too late
for him to sit with the prosecutors.
They themselves said that he
was not providing an interview.
You are saying,
you know he didn't sit down with the FBI,
that's what's understood.
And why should he still
have a conversation
with the FBI to help which case?
Well, it could open up new cases
that is provide evidence for new cases.
So look, anyone who may
have any information
that is relevant
to crimes against
children should volunteer
to speak to law enforcement,
FBI, state law enforcement,
anywhere else, not have to be
dragged kicking and screaming
or just try to avoid it completely.
Perhaps he would say he
doesn't have any information.
He's not here to speak
to what you are saying,
he has always denied
wrongdoing, but perhaps-
Well, that's complete...
That's perhaps his reason.
That is complete and utter nonsense,
that he has no information whatsoever.
He stayed in the residence
of Jeffrey Epstein
with Jeffrey Epstein when
young girls were coming
and going from that
residence in Manhattan,
he also visited other residences
of Jeffrey Epstein, other properties.
We know that, that's a matter
of fact, not speculation,
to say that he has no
information is just not true.
And even he has not dared to say it.
It's completely false.
Gloria, when you are
on the case for people,
largely it's been women, lots
of the cases you work on,
we never hear about,
but there are some very
high profile cases,
you are known for your ability,
your mastery to get attention,
to pull stunts to call press conferences,
whether it's a school bus,
whether it's get people
in front of a camera,
I'm sure you have to work
with those women as well
to get them ready for
those sorts of situations.
What do you make of some of the criticism
that you have faced about that approach,
that being one of your
hallmarks, if you like?
Emma, there are many people who think
that women should have
to suffer in silence.
I'm not one of them.
I think that women should have a voice.
They should be able to
speak truth to power.
They should be able to speak out
about the injustices against
them in an appropriate case,
depending on what their goal is.
And only after they've been advised
of the benefits and
risks of that decision,
which is what I do.
Have you been disappointed at points
by some of the men that
you've come up against
because maybe you were
a fan of their work,
you'd enjoyed their music,
you'd watch their, I don't
know, sporting performance,
have you had that moment
that some people have when
they hear about somebody,
when they're found guilty
and they thought "no, not that person".
Have you had that?
Not really.
No?
Because I'm just very
goal-oriented for my clients
who are victims.
I know that many celebrities
lead double lives
or triple lives where the character
or the brand that they've created
are not who they are in real life.
And so I don't buy into the fantasy.
You can only be disappointed
if you have expectations
that are different than the reality.
My expectations are,
that often celebrities will take advantage
of their celebrity status
against vulnerable victims,
and often against their own fans,
which is very disturbing
because I always feel that
celebrities and powerful people
should feel very blessed about
the privileges that they have
because they are celebrities.
And I often say about
those celebrity attorneys
who represent their clients
who are being accused,
they represent the Hollywood bad boys,
and I represent the women they hurt.
Well, it definitely sounds like
it's changed your whole view
of the world that we live in
and given it a completely
different complexion.
Just finally, in that
documentary about your life
that I'm sure many people
will have seen on Netflix,
in 2015 I believe,
you said you'd had no
holidays in 40 years.
Have you had one since?
I'm hoping perhaps a glimmer
of a break here and there.
Well, there's no holiday from injustice.
Oh, come on, Gloria.
Little bit, a little bit of a break?
A little bit of a break.
When I'm six feet under,
when that day comes,
it will come for all of us.
Maybe I'll have some rest at that time,
although I am considering many ways
that perhaps I can help
even from the grave,
but we have to fight back for women.
It's my duty.
I am blessed to have the
privilege to help others
to rise up, to become empowered.
And that's what this is all about.
And I do not need rest.
If anything, we have a saying, Emma,
that women become more
radical as they get older.
The women's movement is unique
on all movements in that way.
And yes, I see even more need
after 47 years of practicing law
than I did when I began to practice.
So I do have a passion for justice.
I have no interest in holidays.
I only have interest in winning justice,
and that is what I will continue to do.
Gloria, I like that.
I look forward to
getting even more radical
and busy as I get older.
And that's because of our life experience.
It's not because of any
women's studies class
we've ever had.
Women recognize what is
wrong in their lives.
And a matter of fact, if
when I visit some women
in nursing homes and old age homes,
they pick up their canes and
they say, "Gloria, don't stop.
When these men attack you, just
continue and fight harder."
Those women know the truth
about their lives, Emma,
and I am fighting for
all women, young, old
I don't care their color, their religion,
their ethnic origin.
We want them to rise up and
become empowered and fight back,
choose your battles carefully,
but fight back and you can win justice.
Well, on that, I think also
the idea of growing old,
not disgracefully,
but getting more angry
and more active is one.
And it's often said women definitely
made the personal political as well.
Gloria Allred, thank you very much.
Thank you, Emma.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.